[Music]
and use the proves you don't actually
have to announce anything to get hype
wheels turning cyberpunk 2077 has
launched back into the spotlight today
by tweeting the word beep from its
official account just to beep with
asterisks either side 11,000 retweets
and Counting what makes this particular
six character tweet so enticing is that
the official cyberpunk Twitter account
has been inactive since December 5th of
2013 as you'd imagine a ton of buzz has
been generated over this tweet and what
it might mean but a hint may lie in the
Gwent subreddit set a proactive read
community manager Powell byrsa dropped
in on a post about the end of Gwen's
third ranked play season coming to a
close one user asked why the developer
is releasing rewards tomorrow alongside
the patch and not sooner - which Bazaar
replied because we will announce
something cool tomorrow winky face now
this could very well be a Gwent related
announcement but the timing does seem a
little too perfect
or maybe cyberpunk 2077 is a digital
card game now whose Tuesday let me know
what you think or hope is coming down in
that comment box and stay tuned to game
spot for all the latest
[Music]
you